hey guys
welcome back to my endless series of
knocking the later seasons of game of
thrones
there is one aspect about the show that
i haven't gone into enough detail about
yet and that is
the action i think it is very overrated
and there has been a false consensus
that at least the action in season 8 was
good
but even some of the coolest action
scenes in the season
are flawed so i want to take a closer
look as to what the problem is with each
of the action scenes and determine what
they did wrong
so taking a look at the first main
action sequence in season 8
we'll be analyzing the long night this
is undeniably the worst out of all the
action in the season and there are four
main issues as to why that is
first let's start out with the most
simple problem the lighting
so a common role in action is that you
want to see the action
but when you can't see the action you
tend to have problems
most action scenes that are shrouded in
darkness tend to make up for a lack of
quality
and that quality generally includes
choreography sun performance and any
special or visual effects
the reason why the lighting was so dark
was to cheat these fundamentals in
action
and give you something more half-assed
there could have been many reasons as to
why it was half-assed
but i think the main reason is because
of the budget
to create an hour and 20 minute battle
episode with just about 20 million
dollars
the filmmakers probably had to find some
shortcuts
there are a crazy amount of vfx shots
required for the beginning onslaught of
whites
and dragon combat so the only logical
way to save money is to obscure
everything but because of that the end
product was thereby
horrible here is about 20 million
dollars
we just want clear action for the
audience we can put that check in a
money market mutual fund then we'll
reinvest the earnings into foreign
currency accounts with compounding
interest and it's gone
uh what it's gone it's all gone
what's all going the money in your
account it didn't do too well it's gone
to put into perspective taken three was
made for 48 million dollars
so the long night episode had a bigger
challenge to overcome because of its
scale
and i don't really think they overcame
that challenge
since there is so much darkness the
filmmakers can just throw in a bunch of
mediocre action that we can't see
or judge also it's not like night battle
episodes haven't been done in the past
on this very show for example you could
still see the action in blackwater
and you could still see manchester's
army rushing the wall
for these episodes they knew exactly
what they could pull off and they didn't
have to taint the end product because of
budgetary reasons or
time however in the long night whether
it was actually budgetary issues
or david and dan were just so
unbelievably stupid they ended up
ruining the whole episode
the lighting may seem like the most
damning reason as to why the action in
the long night was so bad
but i'd argue that the other issues with
this episode are much
worse for the next issue let's talk
about how jarring the action is
even if you turn up the brightness to
see the action it is way too hard to
follow
for some of these shots we are literally
getting about 16 cuts per 10 seconds
which is crazy
that basically makes everything like an
uncomprehensible mess
and i even found out from slowing the
footage down that they turned one of
these shots upside down
and he thought it was already jarring
enough like we understand that the
whites are ferocious
but you don't have to use extremely fast
editing to deliver that message
because of this it makes the action just
feel unenjoyable and jarring to watch
that is one of the major reasons why the
long night was so underwhelming
people complain about the long night not
being long enough
but the execution of the action is much
worse
for example if we look at hardhome which
deals with a lot of whites
it doesn't feel jarring at all the scene
is well choreographed and each shot has
an actual purpose
it's okay to have some quick shots of
action that are out of context to
establish the chaos in the scene
but you also need choreographed action
with longer takes
this is what hardhome does so well they
find a perfect balance in making the
action feel chaotic but not chaotic
enough to lose the audience
and this is how the long night fails
every shot just feels like noise
and is chaotic for the sake of being
overwhelming and chaotic
there is a complete lack of choreography
really one of the only extended
choreographed fight scenes and the whole
episode
is with arya and that's not enough to
create a nice balance in the action
like it's much easier to have random
people dying everywhere and to have
practically no consistency
instead of having actual fight scenes
that take planning and time to
accomplish
for example we randomly go from jaime
getting jumped on
to a different shot a torment getting
jumped on and we don't get any
resolution as to what happens to them
generally in good action you see both
the action and the reaction in the same
shot
not just does the long night not show us
the action and the reaction in the same
shot
but sometimes they don't even show us
the reaction as to what happens next
it just becomes very dull and
uninteresting when you rely heavily on
this method
on top of there being no lighting
so it seems like the action in long
night can't get worse but it does
and it gets worse through its
presentation of characters
in each of the action scenes for the
long night the creators always present
the characters in impossible odds in
which the only logical outcome for them
is
death this happens constantly and the
most notorious example is where everyone
is in the courtyard surrounded and being
swarmed by whites
in this situation everyone should be
dead and the only reason why they are
all alive
is because of plot armor this whole
scenario destroys their suspension of
disbelief because the whites are
intentionally not killing the main
characters
this degrades the white's lethality and
makes them seem like a joke
in this one shot you see a white hugging
brienne and in the behind the scenes you
see the most silly sight
of whites patiently waiting to attack
the main characters
it just makes the whole sequence seem
like a joke by not having your
characters in realistic situations that
they can overcome
then it creates a situation in which the
characters succeed only because the plot
demands it
and not because they could actually
overcome it this deteriorates the action
because the characters are cheating
their victory over
each obstacle for the last main issue
about the long night i want to go into
the inconsistencies of the antagonist
so right out of the gate we are shown
that the whites are extremely ferocious
and
deadly they literally take out the
entirety of the dothraki in less than a
minute
but all of a sudden when it comes to any
major character they suddenly act
inept and are useless like whites not
being able to kill a fat squabbling
character who can't fight who is other
known as samwell
or even jon snow being surrounded by
hundreds of whites after the night king
resurrected them
there is just a sheer inconsistency of
danger that the whites portray
this breeds a lot of confusion as to
what the whites are capable of and what
their power level is
for most of the antagonists in the show
we have a clear understanding as to how
dangerous they are
for example with joffrey he is
consistently cruel and tortures his
subjects and that comes to be expected
whenever he's being dangerous
however the whites could just be running
over people like the undead horde from
world war z
or they could just be walking at someone
their varying level of danger
is so inconsistent that it literally
confuses the audience as to how
dangerous they are
and this hinders the action because the
whites don't come off as a big challenge
for our heroes
and overcoming challenges is a big part
of action
so those are the four main reasons as to
why i think the long night action
sequence was horrible
so let's now take a look at the extended
action sequence in king's landing
i will look separately at the
destruction of king's landing jaime vs
euron and cleganebowl
first let's take a look at the
destruction of king's landing
the primary issue that i have with the
action in this whole sequence is that it
is spectacle over depth
yes the vfx side of this whole sequence
is very good and is very blockbuster and
fun to watch
but it lacks the depth that the biggest
story event in the show requires
all the depth we get from our characters
is a sudden and unjustified turn from
daenerys that just
confuses the audience stale and
repetitive reaction shots from cersei
that are all interchangeable
a surprised pikachu tyrion and arya
stark that has nine lives
let's get you back in the fight and an
as usual confused jon snow
characters in essence drive the story in
action
since they are all drowned out by the
popcorn visual effects
it loses its weight and emotional impact
an example as to how it lacks depth from
its characters
is that we don't have any reaction shots
of daenerys while she is on a dragon
burning down
king's landing the juiciest part of this
action scene
isn't the explosions but the turn of the
mad queen
after all this is the biggest twist of
the season instead we only get the
explosions and we don't see daenerys for
the rest of the episode
david and dan basically just laid a
carpet of visual effects over the
fundamental heart of this whole action
scene
and because of that it feels more hollow
it's just pure spectacle
and a lot of the destruction turns into
repetitive noise
sure they give us the point of view of
arya to see how bad the destruction is
but she's thereby granted plot armor to
witness all of it
and through arya's perspective it
doubles down on the spectacle side of
the action scene and takes our focus
away from the turn of the mad
queen because of this we miss out on the
emotional core of this whole action
sequence
which is daenerys's turn sure all the
action in king's landing is enjoyable
but since the characters are so drowned
out it loses its emotional punch
and the biggest event in the story is
rendered more hollow
from an over-reliance on spectacle
so going into a more objectively bad
fight scene let's take a look at the
fight between jaime and euron
the reason why this is such an
objectively bad fight scene is because
it's riddled with errors
and bad editing the errors that i'm
referring to are continuity errors
if anyone doesn't know continuity means
the practice of ensuring that details in
a shot
are consistent from shot to shot within
a film scene
and this action scene breaks continuity
so let's take a detailed look for this
shot
jaime gets pushed into a rock by euron
and then in the next shot he suddenly
teleports behind euron and slashes at
him
interesting after that euron throws
jaime into the same rock and we cut to a
shot behind euron and for some reason we
don't see the rock or
jaime and it seems as if euron is even
confused
and again jaime teleports behind euron
and tackles him
i don't know if that is a magical rock
of teleportation or
if there are actually multiple
continuity errors
but yeah on top of the fast cuts this
action scene is pretty unbearable to
watch
it's crazy how we have this fight scene
in the same episode of cleganebowl
it goes to show how little the creators
cared about euron and jaime and put
practically no
effort into it the actor who plays euron
said they had about two days to film the
action
and it goes to show in the end product
granted the audience were probably just
rolling their eyes at this point
but david and dan could have at least
made up for it with a good fight scene
[Music]
so for the last action scene in season 8
which is cleganebowl
i don't think there's a lot wrong with
it i think it is genuinely a good action
scene and is basically self-contained
and doesn't have much to do with the
rest of the story
like hell cersei the main villain walks
right by clegane and he does nothing
because the mountain is the villain in
clegane's story
the only issue i have with this action
scene is that it cuts away when it gets
the most interesting
i'm not talking about the cool intercut
sequence between ari and the hound
getting pummeled
but i'm talking about right when the
fight gets into the epic sword play
they cut away to cersei bumbling around
when we get back to the fight we have
very little swordplay and then we go
straight into the getting pummeled
section of the fight scene and that's
basically
it all the buildup of eight seasons
essentially mounts to a fight that lasts
about two minutes
with the inclusion of a cutaway if the
actual fight between the two characters
was longer we would have had more payoff
and the dual aspect could have been more
reminiscent of the earlier seasons
these two characters deserved more well
choreographed action
because they are the best fighters in
game of thrones also the mountain has
been sitting around for the past 3
seasons
so you think they would give us more
action from his character to justify all
that build up
and that's really the only criticism i
have for cleganebowl besides that
i think the rest of the action scene is
good although i'm not really here to
talk about what was good but instead
look at all the issues and the action
but yeah that basically encompasses most
the action in season eight
the long night was just a complete mess
with a lot of issues while the
destruction of king's landing was
enjoyable
but it still had some issues overall the
action has evolved greatly over the
course of the entire show
the scale of it has increased
significantly and generally when you
have to deal with higher skill action
it is much harder to pull off
you